التعليم ام الخبز الصحه ام الملبس كثير من
هذه الخيارات سقطت من حسابات اللبنانيين
في ظل فقر يتوحش على طول البلاد وعرضها
بعد بعض الحقوق الادميه باتت من الكماليات
في لبنان فالتعليم بالنسبه لحالات اصبحت
طرفا بمعنى ان الحق في الغذاء يتعرض
لتهديد شديد في المجتمع يومين رايت واتش
في تقرير سابق لها وجدت ان انعدام الامن
الغذائي قد وصل الى مستويات تنذر بالخطر
لكن الى اي حد الى حد ان تعيش عائلات
الجوع بما فيها الاطفال كما تقول المنظمه
فهل فعلا وصل الامر الى هذا الحد نعم
واسوا من ذلك
يعني بحسب الطبخه بروح وبيجي بالسوق 100
مره قدام معي هالقد هاي بتكلف هاي قديه
بتكلف حتى اقدر اجيبها
ما اعطتني كافيه عند الحكيم ما بيرحموا
اذا واحد ضرسه
في بركان جوا معشعش جوا يعني بس ناطر بس
هيك نتفه صغيره
الان ايضا من فيض وزاره الشؤون الاجتماعيه
تقول انها تلقت 500 الف طلب من اسر
لبنانيه اعلنت فقرها صنف منها 300
الفا الف الف ضمن الاسر الاكثر فقرا في
البلاد اللبنانيون اليوم يمزقهم الالفقر
هناك مليونا ونصف المليون لبناني تحتها خط
الفقر ومليونين ونصف المليون فوقه وفقا
لدراسه للامم المتحده الوضع اذا مازوم
وكارثي للغايه